huh weird what's weird I I you know I I
just bought a a few scratches myself I
didn't win anything though it's a Fool's
paths or riches but I did notice every
ticket has a a serial number it's
printed right there on the on the side
and well our serial numbers are out to
be they're sequential
that means in order I know so so then I
remembered that I saw this trucker
playing one of those kinds of scratch
outs this morning it was a gold rusher
it was it right before I picked up my
car which was right before you bought
your ticket
this trucker he didn't win anything yeah
and he threw it away you know I know but
743-6-3
454.
and the number on this ticket it ends in
so that means if you uh really bought
your ticket after this guy well then
your number it would end with a
455 or maybe
56 yeah you know even 57.
but it doesn't right
no your ticket number is 450.
print
or maybe
Maybe
you didn't buy that ticket at all
maybe Damien bought that ticket last
night like he did every night and maybe
he brought it up to the roof
yeah and and maybe when it was just the
two of you alone out there
well he realized
he'd won
and maybe
you killed him for it
I didn't do it I know you did you
[__] there you go
everything all right in here
oh yeah we're just yeah sorry there's a
turned up a little bit too high
yeah you okay you good yeah she's just
getting out of here all right I'll go
warm it up the car
yeah okay
wow you got me
I did it
so why don't we call the cops
sure they'd love to hear us um
half-baked theory about serial numbers
from a vagrant who
lives in her car
it's not just a theory
you admitted it
to you
you're not a cop you're just some
woman
got no proof I'm not on camera like your
friend
if I'm wrong
let's give them a call
we can tell them hey
Shed from the rest stop at 421 Route 66
and uh sorry what's your name Charlie
kale your registration's in the glove
box did you know that you're a person of
interest in a bunch of deaths in Nevada
I sure the cops would love to talk to
you
what's that
nothing
if I were you
get in my trash bucket not speed the
[__] out of here
I call the cops
on you
all set ready to go
have a safe trip
[Music]